[Music]
tropical storm harvey has forced
thousands of people from their homes
along with countless pets many are now
abandoned lost or homeless major storms
can be especially cruel to animals maria
villarreal is in san antonio texas at a
shelter housing pets with nowhere to go
maria good morning
good morning i'm about 200 miles east of
houston in san antonio's animal care
services shelter they are working with
the humane society of the united states
to clear out this shelter they want to
make room for any evacuated pets that
are affected by hurricane harvey so by
this time tomorrow all these cats in
here will be on a plane headed to oregon
we could only
take this dog charlie because the waters
were too high when autumn henley
evacuated she had to leave three of her
dogs behind and hope for the best
luckily a family that lived in the
neighborhood had a boat
and they went back and rescued the other
three dogs from the upstairs bathroom
she and her dogs are now staying at the
george r convention center in houston
which has been accepting pets since
sunday night
volunteers are working to give pet
owners what they need
you need
very basic things
warm blankets food crates
across hurricane ravaged texas
owners neighbors and good samaritans are
doing what they can to rescue
four-legged friends
and it's not just pet owners that need
help ranchers have had to drive their
cattle to higher ground as well we're
looking at a dire situation and not just
for people but for pets
lisa norwood is with the city of san
antonio animal care services where later
today they're crating up sheltered dogs
and cats and sending them to cities
across the country to make room for pets
separated from their owners during
hurricane harvey these cats arrived in
san diego on monday
with punishing rain still falling going
home is not yet an option for many
whether on two legs or four
people love their animals it's just it's
heartbreaking and
people are taking good care of their
animals are doing the best they can
during hurricane katrina we saw a lot of
people that were refusing to evacuate
without their pets and right now that is
happening in houston that's why a
project like this is so important the
animal care services out of san antonio
has taken in roughly about 200 evacuated
pets most of them are dogs but there's
about 50 cats and one gerbil named rufus
maurice
okay maria thank you so much unless you
have a pet i don't know if you really
get it
because there's a real bond with this
pet and it fits both ways it goes both
ways they are really uh four-legged
people with in people clothes
in dog clothes because they are really
like a member of the family there's no
question about that i can't imagine a
difficult decision to leave
no doubt